well the night's not only inspiring the
Next Generation but those who've been
heating up ice for decades yeah so the
elders skatesman that's a group of
hockey players here in the valley 50 and
older I love the name Elder Scapes they
play at Pepsi Ice Arena and that's where
we find Candace Charles live this
morning in North Las Vegas with their
story Candace good morning to you
good morning John I hear they've been
able to teach you a thing or two and I
think they do as well when they slice up
the ice here at the Pepsi Ice Arena of
course it's always a great time they
tell them that the knights give them not
only that great energy but creativity
and remind them that as soon as you step
on the ice you can turn into a kid again
young at heart but wise enough to know
anyone can play the game the Elder
scates men have been heating up the ice
for more than two decades we got to see
the evolution and the growth of the game
and with the NHL and DGK having more
people get interested in this beautiful
game that we've loved all our lives
former Team USA hockey player bills
ebony said
Club Germany is the president leading
the team of 50 year olds and older go
get him go get them and don't worry
about these guys getting hurt it's
hockey yeah you brush it off you get
back on the ice as long as you you know
put in the time and the effort to get
out there and skate and practice anybody
can play Ford Patrick Quinn hits the ice
three times a week I'm 58 now I hope to
be doing it when I'm 78 and he would be
an amazing company the oldest player is
82. and I feel so lucky to be part of
this group because the guys are just
great the hockey's fun the exercise you
can't do any better than that and when
the night's on the way to Gold there's
more than black and gold on the team
jersey on the ice at Pepsi Arena it's in
the Elder scatesman's blood when I
watched the golden knights play and they
make a certain move or a certain play
it's like I want to try it out when I
get out on the ice it doesn't always
work out as well as it does on the uh
for the nights but it's uh it kind of
promotes that creativity that you might
be a little bit grayer and probably a
little bit is slower but still
ultimately we enjoy this game
as you can see people are riled up and
ready to go it's going to be an exciting
couple of days nobody's there tells me
that he's actually an amputee and when
he gets out on the ice here he's
reminded to push forward and we're
hoping that the knights are the same all
the way to the Stanley Cup for now live
from the Pepsi Ice Arena I'm Candace
Charles 8 News Now
[Laughter]